Water… water…
I’m so… thirsty…
Is that tap?
Nah, I’m good.
Hey there parched party people, Jules here
for DNews.
There’s a theory that when you’\e hungry
and you eat a meal, your body takes about
20 minutes for the “I’m full” signal
to reach your brain.
This “fullness gap” can lead to overeating,
which can lead to fatness.
But despite this slow moving phenomenon with
hunger, the same doesn’t seem to exist with
thirst.
Quenching thirst happens immediately, and
over watering isn’t really something people
do by accident.
So… what’s the difference and why do we
get thirsty in the thirst place?
Well, mainly so we don’t die.
Water is THE most important nutrient for basically
all animals, it’s one of the big reasons
we are all able to live and survive on earth,
which is roughly 71% of water.
Humans, are about 60% water and this proportion
matters.
Because when water leaves your body by sweating,
pooping, peeing, breathing, and crying, as
we all do every day, it needs to be replaced.
The brain is able to control your body through
electrical impulses that run through electrolytes,
like salt, in your cells.
When the balance of electrolytes is off and
you become dehydrated, it may be harder to
move, think, see, and it can literally kill
you.
So, simply enough, thirst, is the body’s
response to unbalanced fluid levels in your
bloodstream.
At least, that’s what we’ve always thought.
See when your brain detects that your blood
is too salty, neurons fire and generate a
“thirst response”.
But once you’ve had some water, just like
with food, it takes at least a little bit
of time for your blood levels to normalize.
Yet, drinking water, especially COLD water,
seems to immediately satisfy the feeling of
thirst, even before your blood levels are
healthy again.
Why is thirst instant, but hunger takes time?
Well, it turns out that brains are a little
smarter than us.
See, overeating is actually kind of a good
thing -- at least to the brain.
We can store food as fat and use it later
for energy, and there’s no reason to stop
eating when we’re hungry because our mammalian
ancestors didn’t have swimsuit season.
On the other hand, drinking too much water
in too short a time can literally kill you.
According to the American Chemistry Society,
it can take less than two gallons of water
to kill a 165-pound person.
So how does the brain know when to stop drinking?
Well, a 2016 study on thirst in mice by researchers
from the University of California, San Francisco,
found that an area of the brain called the
subfornical organ, reacts immediately to oral
stimulation.
Neurons within the SFO are actually able to
predict your future fluid levels based on
your current blood composition and how much
water or food is in your mouth.
When they think you’ve had enough, they
stop firing and you stop feeling thirsty.
That’s pretty amazing, since a miscalculation
on your brain’s part could literally kill
you.
What’s even more amazing is that these neurons
don’t just react to moisture, but to temperature
as well.
Researchers found that in mice, cold liquids
dulled the thirst neurons faster than warmer
liquids, and even just cooling the mouth could
inhibit the thirst response, without introducing
any liquid at all.
These thirst neurons are an incredible discovery,
because not only are they able to parse data
from a number of different, and tangentially
related sources; the mouth, the brain, the
blood, but they also automatically make predictions
based on that information.
But despite the incredible nature of thirst,
there’s absolutely nothing the subfornical
organ can do about how thirsty we are for
Channing Tatum.
So what happens when all that crying and pooping
leaves you dehydrated?
Find out in this video from Trace!
What’s your favorite way to quench your
thirst?
Let us know in the comments, don’t forget
to like this video, and be sure to subscribe
for more DNews every day of the week.